[Música]
son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna seguimos comentandoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
el tribunal constitucional de Perú
ordenó la anulación del proceso contra
el presidente Pedro Castillo por
presunta traición a la patria por haber
declarado que su país podría facilitar
una salida al mar Para Bolivia la
demanda podía generar la inhabilitación
del mandatario pero la corte aceptó un
recurso de habeas Corpus de la defensa
Tenemos reporte
en Brasil el partido liberal que apoyó
la candidatura del presidente Jair
bolsonaro a las presidenciales de
octubre pidió invalidar los resultados
de las urnas electrónicas más antiguas
usadas durante esa jornada el Tribunal
Superior electoral condicionó la
aceptación de la demanda que también se
han cuestionados los resultados de la
primera vuelta
Naciones Unidas presentó un informe en
el que analiza los últimos 10 años de
Colombia en materia de desarrollo humano
el texto destaca que el acuerdo de paz
con las extintas Farc mejoró Los
indicadores del país pero la pandemia y
la crisis climática frenan la evolución
[Aplausos]
[Música]
comenzamos en Perú donde el tribunal
constitucional ordenó la anulación del
proceso que adelantaba el congreso
contra el presidente Pedro Castillo por
presunta traición a la patria luego de
que afirmara que su país ha podido
facilitar una salida al mar Para Bolivia
previamente conversamos con Francisco
Zacarías corresponsal en Perú que nos
explicó qué argumentó el tribunal para
anular el pedido que ya había sido
aprobado por la subcomisión de
acusaciones constitucionales
les cuento que el tribunal
constitucional de este país declaró
fundada la demanda de habas Corpus
presentada por el presidente Pedro
Castillo porque considera que la
acusación de traición a la patria
formulada por el parlamento peruano
carece de fundamentación objetiva no esa
Correa con los parámetros de
razonabilidad y transgrede el debido
proceso en la sede parlamentaria en
realidad diversos juristas ya venían
criticando este procedimiento del
Congreso peruano porque señalan ellos
que el presidente Pedro Castillo jamás
violó la ley peruana ni tampoco violentó
la Constitución Política de este país al
ofrecer una salida al mar a Para Bolivia
durante una entrevista que brindó a
enero de este año señalan que solamente
fueron declaraciones palabras opiniones
y en ese país opinar no es delito
entonces por eso convalidan la decisión
del tribunal constitucional Pero bueno
qué es lo que viene ahora este esta
sentencia el tribunal constitucional le
arruina los planes
y los opositores del presidente Castillo
en el parlamento porque ahora van a
necesitar recurrir a un proceso de
vacancia presidencial o un impeachment
para tratar de sacarle el cargo al
presidente de castillo y para ellos se
necesiten se necesitan 87 votos que
ahorita no pueden reunirlos Esa es la
situación vamos a Brasil porque el
partido liberal que apoyó la candidatura
a la reelección del presidente Yahir
bolsonaro presentó una acusación ante el
tribunal superior electoral para pedir
que se anulen los resultados de la
segunda vuelta de las presidenciales que
ganó el izquierdista Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva el documento solicita anular
los votos registrados en unas 350.000
urnas electrónicas que son las más
antiguas utilizadas durante la jornada
argumentando que los resultados son
imposibles de auditar El supremo
condicionó la aceptación de la demanda
que también se presente un requerimiento
sobre la primera vuelta en la que se
usaron las mismas urnas esto en este
caso no mayor a 24 horas según lo
determinado por nuestra área técnica
contratada estas inconsistencias no
permiten dar fe del resultado o que
dichas urnas registraron efectivamente
el resultado electoral
vengo a decir que hoy estamos aquí con
una sola intención contribuir al
fortalecimiento de la democracia en
nuestro país
en otras noticias en Colombia el
programa de Naciones Unidas para el
desarrollo presentó el capítulo de su
informe final dedicado a analizar la
evolución de los últimos 10 años de ese
país en materia de desarrollo humano el
acuerdo de paz entre las extintas FARC y
el estado mejorado Los indicadores pero
la pandemia y la crisis climática se han
convertido en el principal freno de la
evolución esto según el texto lluís
Muñoz tiene más detalles
logros importantes en Colombia pero
marcados por la pandemia es la
conclusión del programa de Naciones
Unidas para el desarrollo en su informe
sobre la evolución de la última década
con un claro éxito
es el acuerdo el acuerdo de La Habana el
acuerdo de paz el acuerdo entre el
estado y las FARC de 2016 coincide con
una disminución permanente en la tasa de
homicidios como se observa en la Gráfica
los asesinatos en Colombia entre 2003 y
2011 pasaron de 57,81 a 36,20 por cada
100.000 habitantes con un descenso que
se mantuvo hasta 2021 cuando cayó a un
27,74 sin embargo el informe advierte de
que después del acuerdo de paz ha habido
un incremento en indicadores de
violencia marcado por un fenómeno nuevo
el asesinato de líderes sociales
medioambientales y excombatientes de las
FARC el ámbito de mayor preocupación
para Colombia es el medio ambiente y la
crisis climática
entre el año 2012 y 2020 se han
deforestado más de 1,3 millones de
hectáreas esto es un 71% más respecto a
la década anterior Mientras que el 47%
del país es decir 184 municipios
presentan valores catalogados con riesgo
alto y muy alto en cuanto a la crisis
climática la última década ha sido de
Gran éxito en indicadores sociales como
la reducción en la desigualdad de
ingresos de pobreza monetaria el aumento
de escolaridad y una mayor cobertura
educativa y de acceso a la salud sin
embargo después de la pandemia de covid
19 cayó el índice de desarrollo humano
por primera vez en la historia El pib se
contrajo en un 7% el desempleo creció en
5 puntos 3,6 millones de personas
cayeron en pobreza monetaria y 2,8
millones en pobreza monetaria extrema
indicadores que el nuevo gobierno de
izquierda de Gustavo Petro se ha puesto
como objetivo revertir en los próximos
cuatro años
en El Salvador el Ministerio de defensa
informó que se han incautado 12,8
toneladas de diferentes tipos de droga
en lo que va del año las autoridades
señalaron que desde junio de 2019 cuando
nayib bukele asumió la presidencia la
cifra de drogas decomisadas asciende a
28,4 toneladas el último decomiso se
realizó el pasado 14 de noviembre cuando
un cargamento de más de tres toneladas
de cocaína con un costo de unos 79
millones de dólares fue interceptado en
el Pacífico en una lancha conducida por
tres ciudadanos ecuatorianos
Anthony facchi el principal asesor
médico de la Casa Blanca se retirará en
diciembre y hoy fue su última
comparecencia oficial amado y odiado su
presencia representa la lucha de Estados
Unidos contra la pandemia de Kobe 19
primero bajo la administración de Donald
Trump y luego con el gobierno de Joe
biden Rafael Pérez nos cuenta más sobre
el hombre que delineo la forma en que
Estados Unidos enfrentó la pandemia
adiós a uno de los rostros más vistos de
la Casa Blanca en los últimos años
jefe del instituto de alergias y
enfermedades infecciosas y principal
asesor médico de la Casa Blanca confirmó
su retiro su voz se escuchó por última
vez en rueda de prensa a este martes
nuevamente con el parte y las
recomendaciones para enfrentar el 19
dejaré que otras personas juzguen el
valor o no de mis logros pero lo que me
gustaría Es que la gente Recuerde lo que
hice todos los días durante estos años
di todo lo que tengo y nunca dejé nada
en el campo
el que también fue asesor del gobierno
Trump representó la respuesta de Estados
Unidos ante la pandemia
hemos visto de manera tan dramática en
la televisión a personas que se
congregan en multitudes en bares sin
máscaras o lugares llenos de personas
sin máscaras
seguro que eso ha conducido al rebrote
que hemos visto
amado Y odiado tuvo varios momentos de
desencuentro con su jefe anterior que en
varias ocasiones se negó a usar
mascarilla
Simplemente no quiero usar una es una
recomendación ellos lo recomiendan me
siento bien Simplemente no quiero estar
No sé de alguna manera sentado en la
oficina oval detrás del escritorio
resolute el gran escritorio resolute y
usar cubrebocas para saludar presidentes
primeros ministros dictadores Reyes y
reinas
en diciembre tras 54 años de trabajo
ininterrumpidos los republicanos han
prometido investigarlo el funcionario de
81 años dijo que cooperará en caso de
que esto pase
cambiamos de tema porque la Organización
Mundial de la Salud advirtió sobre el
peligro de muerte en Ucrania tras la
llegada del invierno pues se prevé que
existen en temperaturas de hasta 20
grados bajo cero Durante los próximos
meses las autoridades ucranianas
iniciaron la evacuación de miles de
personas hacia zonas que son
consideradas seguras la OMS también
estimó que unos 10 millones de
ciudadanos corren el riesgo de sufrir
enfermedades mentales por el conflicto
Andrés triviño con los detalles
un invierno que desafiará la
supervivencia la Organización Mundial de
la Salud advirtió que Las bajas
temperaturas amenazarán la vida de
millones de ucranianos esto luego de
estimar que al menos el 50% de la
infraestructura energética del país ha
sido destruida por los ataques rusos lo
que deja pronósticos alarmantes
Esperamos que entre dos y tres millones
de personas adicionales abandonen sus
hogares en busca de calor y seguridad se
enfrentarán a desafíos de salud únicos
que incluyen infecciones respiratorias
como el Kobe 19 neumonía influenza y un
riesgo grave de difteria y sarampión en
una población insuficientemente
inmunizada
desde que inició la Guerra hace casi
nueve meses se han registrado más de 700
ataques contra hospitales y centros de
salud de Ucrania lo que representa una
violación al derecho internacional Según
denunció la OMS por otro lado detalló
que el conflicto le generará
enfermedades mentales como estrés agudo
ansiedad depresión y trastorno
postraumático a unos 10 millones de
ucranianos las ciudades del país tienen
constantes cortes de energía y la
mayoría se encuentran sin suministro de
gas por lo que el gobierno evacúa a los
residentes principalmente en la región
de miko Life y la recién recuperada
ciudad de gerson
nos vamos ahora porque da miedo dormir
por la noche esperaremos hasta que la
situación mejore y luego volveremos a
casa
nadie quiere salir de sus hogares pero
nos aconsejaron irnos para ahorrar
energía Y dejarla para los que están
luchando por Ucrania entonces este vídeo
tú podemos usar las autoridades pidieron
a quienes viven en el extranjero que no
regresen a Ucrania durante el invierno
para conservar la energía y destinar la
hospitales y otras instalaciones clave
en Grecia una embarcación con cerca de
500 migrantes a bordo que había metido
una señal de auxilio en altamar atracón
en un puerto de La Isla griega de Creta
las autoridades elenas indicaron que los
migrantes no han desembarcado pero se
encuentran a salvo después de que un
barco pesquero lo remolcara en una
operación de traslado de Gran dificultad
debido al fuerte viento reinante en la
zona y condiciones climáticas adversas
dos buques de carga petrolero y dos
pesqueros italianos también estaban en
la zona prestosas a dar ayuda en el
operativo
la migración hacia Estados Unidos
registra
récords en América Latina muchos que ven
imposible llegar permanecer en México
donde está floreciendo una nueva
economía informal pero también de
remesas especialmente entre los
ciudadanos haitianos lluis Muñoz tiene
más detalles
una nueva economía en México aquellos
que no han podido llegar a Estados
Unidos y se han quedado en el sur del
país fronterizo tratan de sobrevivir con
la mente informal de productos
especialmente entre los haitianos
tercera nacionalidad que más solicita
asilo en México ya hay mucho de ellos
como estoy haciendo ahora vendiendo
pasar el momento Hasta Que Salga mi
protocolo para salir del país buscan
métodos para subsistir para mí aquí en
Tapachula es un lugar bien bien bonita
es bueno tienes muchas personas buenas a
ayudar nosotros
pero más allá del mercado informal
también destaca la reconversión
económica especialmente en las remesas
México registró un récord en los tres
primeros trimestres del año recibiendo
cerca de 43 mil millones de dólares del
exterior la fuente de ingresos de los
envíos
y remesas que los extranjeros que viven
en Estados Unidos le mandan constituye
al día de hoy la primer fuente de
ingresos para nosotros los ciudadanos en
la plaza principal de Tapachula hay un
mercado informal que llega hasta las
Divisas es un reflejo del alto flujo
migratorio hacia Estados Unidos donde en
su frontera se ha registrado un recorte
en 2022 de más de 2,76 millones de
personas detenidas
finalizamos en Berlín la capital alemana
que encendió su iluminación navideña
Este martes en medio de la crisis
energética que vive Europa las
autoridades locales defendieron que en
el momento difícil el que se vive en el
Continente particularmente en Alemania
es importante que las luces brillen para
brindar Esperanza
140.000 bombillos led iluminarán la
calle comercial más importante de Berlín
los responsables señalaron que las luces
el led y la reducción de los tiempos de
encendido habituales disminuyen el
consumo en un 30%. así llegamos al final
de esta emisión de directo América aquí
en France 24 a ustedes Les agradecemos
su sintonía y los invitamos a continuar
con nosotros que ya llega Andrés espinal
con toda la información de nuestra red
de corresponsales en el mundo feliz
noche para todos
[Música]